today's protagonist helped wage war against the
u.s government in defense of his people's land
and if it's war you're looking to wage that
i've got good news for you because today's
video is sponsored by conflict of nations a free
online strategy game that pits millions of players
against each other worldwide in conflict of
nations you fight up to 64 other players in real
time games that can take weeks to complete the
game is set in the early 21st century and features
modern day weapons and technology your objective
is to take over the world to find your own
strategy build powerful armies by combining dozens
of different types of infantry tanks and planes
and fight for world domination in a challenging
pvp environment if real-time modern warfare
sounds like your kind of game you can join
a huge community of millions of players both
in the game and on discord and use your diplomatic
skills to forge alliances with other players
everything is fully optimized for cross-platform
gaming play with the same account on both pc
and mobile so if this sounds like your kind of
game click the link in the description below to
jump into a game of conflict of nations and as a
special bonus you guys will receive a special gift
when you sign up using my link you can snag
13 000 gold a month of premium subscription
for free so click the link in the
description below choose a country
and fight your way to victory in epic
real-time battles see on the battlefield
to lakota sitting bull was their greatest leader
the one who tried to guide and protect them
during a time of great and violent turmoil so
the american government sitting bull started
off simply as an annoying obstacle
but became much more than that
after handing them their humiliating
defeat at the battle of a little bighorn
afterward he turned into a dangerous spark one
which they feared could ignite the powder keg
right when they were almost finished subjugating
the native american tribes to himself sitting
ball was a man looking to preserve the
past completely defiant when it came to
his refusal to abandon the old ways of his
people even if this meant war and even death
right off the bat we have a bit of controversy
regarding sitting bull's birthplace as there's
some disagreement between the official version and
the information passed down through oral tradition
according to the history books sitting bull was
born circa 1831 in modern-day south dakota on
the bank of the grand river however some of
his descendants assert that the tribal leader
was actually born in montana near modern-day
mars city on the bank of the yellowstone river
sitting bull was part of the hunk papa lakota
tribe themselves a subdivision of the sioux people
his name in the lakota language was tatanka
leotarko which literally translates as
buffalo bull who sits down but that was not the
name that he had as a child when he was born he
was given the name jumping badger and later
acquired the nickname slow for his restrained
and calculated demeanor his father and his uncles
were all tribal chiefs there was a lot of pressure
for jumping badger following their footsteps
fortunately the young lakota seemed determined
to cast off the moniker slow which he wasn't
too fond of and display the four virtues which
were considered fundamental to the lakota bravery
wisdom fortitude and generosity from an early age
he took part in many games and competitions that
tested his skills and he showed his mettle when
he took down his first buffalo when he was only 10
years old when he turned 14 years of age jumping
badger was given his first opportunity to count
coup this meant striking an enemy up close and was
the most common way of gaining war honours among
the native american tribes of the great plains
it could have been done with the hand a weapon
or a whip but it was most commonly done with a
coup stick a long peeled wand with a feather on
the end the challenge was getting close enough
to the enemy to touch him and then escape without
getting injured or killed it was generally seen as
more honorable than killing or scalping the enemy
but at the same time it was a great humiliation
for the target so most native warriors would have
gone to great lengths to avoid being the ones that
someone else counted kuan anyway when he
was 14 jumping badger was presented with
a coup stick and joined a lakota war
party on a raid against the crow who
were their greatest enemy at the time during the
fight the young man was successful in counting
coup against a crow warrior this filled his
father with pride and when they returned home
the tribe had a ceremony to honor the young
warrior and mark his passage into adulthood he
also received a new name that was more worthy
of him and jumping badger became sitting bull
at 14 sitting ball was already regarded as a
warrior and he continued his meteoric rise through
the ranks of the lakota tribe he was a member of
several groups most notably of the strong heart
society which was made up of the bravest and most
elite warriors he was then given the prestigious
title of sash wearer and became the leader of the
group in 1856. sitting ball proved himself to be
a natural leader and it was only fitting that he
became one of the people who shaped their tribe's
relationships with the outside world particularly
after his father was killed in a fight with a crow
warrior at first he was indifferent to the u.s
government and white settlers he said i have seen
nothing that the white man has which is as good as
our right to roam and live on the open plains as
we choose that being said he wasn't hostile either
growing up most of the interactions with white
people that he experienced were positive since
most of them involved fur traders who were eager
to stay on friendly terms with the lakota but as
settlers and prospectors kept expanding westward
animosity developed on both sides that inevitably
turned violent this resulted in the dakota war of
1862 also known by many other names such as the
sioux uprising or little crows war the conflict
started in minnesota which had only become a
state a few years earlier to help colonize the
territory the u.s government passed the homestead
act in 1862 which promised 160 acres of land to
any person or family who claimed that land and
then lived and cultivated it for five years
most of that territory originally belonged
to native american groups such as the dakota
and ojibwe people on paper the american government
obtained all the land fair and square by either
buying it directly or setting up reservations
where the native tribes were supposed to receive
regular payments and supply shipments but the
government regularly broke the treaties which
were heavily in their favor to begin with payments
were missed supplies were late and contracts were
renegotiated to get more and more concessions
by 1858 the dakota people from minnesota lived
on a small strip of land and many of them were
starving due to the lack of food shipments and
their inability to hunt frustration turned to
anger which turned to violence in 1862 a faction
of dakota warriors led by chief little crow
began raiding settlements and stores launching a
six-week long war that saw the deaths of over 350
settlers the civil war slowed down the government
response but the dakota eventually fought an
army consisting mainly of volunteers they were
decisively defeated at the battle of wood lake
and littlecrow was later killed during a raiding
party afterwards dozens of dakota warriors
were hanged for their role in the war and
the government voided all treaties with the dakota
people forcing them to leave minnesota altogether
sitting bull had no role in this war but his
people and many other tribes suffered the
consequences all the same as the government
decided to punish all the sioux by sending
military expeditions into their territory to
push them back even further it was in june
1863 that sitting bull first fought the united
states army but this was just a minor skirmish
a real fight occurred a year later on july 28 1864
at the battle of kildare mountain this conflict
involved around 4 000 soldiers in total which may
have been the largest single battle between the
u.s army and the plains tribes larger than the
more famous battle of little bighorn that we'll
cover in a bit on one side there were two brigades
led by brigadier general alfred sully around
2200 soldiers their mission usually referred
to as sully's expedition was to weaken the
sioux however possible and get them to relocate
further west best way to do this was to destroy
their villages they had already done it once back
at white stone hill back in september 1863 and now
they had their sights set on a new target an even
larger sioux encampment near the little missouri
river in present-day dunn county north dakota on
the other side were around 1 600 warriors most
of them belonging to various lakota tribes sitting
bull was there as the leader of the papa alongside
another famed warrior named gaul sally was
expecting an enemy force double even triple
what he actually encountered but he had superior
firepower which also included two cannons the
fight was fairly one-sided that lakota tried a
few times to charge into the ranks of the army
soldiers but their guns kept the warriors at
bay until they finally reached within cannon
range once that happened the battle was pretty
much over sully batted the village with cannon
fire until the inhabitants had no choice but to
abandon it the following day his men marched into
the settlement and destroyed everything including
food and supplies so that the lakota would have no
reason to return for many warriors like sitting
bull it was the first time that they encountered
artillery in battle and were finally realizing
the strength that they were up against even so
they did not retreat completely and instead kept
harassing sully's troops with small raids as
the army made its way through the rugged hills
and the steep ravines west of kildare mountain
this eventually culminated in the battle of
the badlands almost two weeks after their first
conflict once again superior firepower won the
day and sully ended his military campaign once
the lakota had been driven into montana during
this time sitting bull was hardly the only lakota
leader who fought the united states army in
1866 another violent conflict emerged known
as red cloud's war which was led by chief
red clown leader of the oglala lakota people
for two years he fought the u.s army for control
of the powder river country region in wyoming
strictly speaking when a treaty had been
signed that land belonged to the crow people
however the oglala fought them over it the same
way that they had done for centuries and they won
so they considered the territory rightfully theirs
then the u.s government tried taking advantage of
the situation to drive them away since that was an
important piece of land that territory contained
part of the bozeman trail which at that time
was the shortest route that took settlers and
prospectors from the oregon trail in wyoming to
the gold rush region of montana it was a route
that the government desperately wanted to control
so they tried building several new forts to gain
a foothold in the area what made this conflict
notable was that it ended in a victory for the
lakota for most of the war red cloud and his
allies which included sitting bull resorted to
raids and other blitz attacks that being said
there were a few large-scale battles such as
the fetterman fight which ended in decisive
victories for the dakota eventually the u.s
government sought peace and signed the treaty
of fort laramie in 1868 the military agreed to
abandon the forts and retreat from the area
more importantly the treaty established the
gracie reservation a large swath of land
that was reserved for native people it
also recognized the black hills in the dakota
territory as being unseated territory that was
sacred to the lakota as their place of
origin and granted them exclusive use of it
around 130 tribal leaders signed the treaty of
fort laramie but sitting bull was not one of them
he didn't do it because he didn't want to move
his people or change their way of life but his
actions proved somewhat prophetic because it took
the united states government less than a decade
to break the treaty once they discovered
that there was gold in those hills
throughout the late 1860s and early 1870s
sitting bull continued to carry out minor
skirmishes against various parties that entered
lakota territory most notable of all being a
group working for the northern pacific railway who
wanted to lay down track over land which sitting
bull considered to belong to the hong papa some
sources claim that during this time sitting bull
became the supreme chief of sioux nation but
others strongly contend that no such position
existed at most sitting bull came to be regarded
as the unofficial leader of the non-treaty lakota
meaning all the native americans who refused to
sign and adhere to the treaty of fort laramie
and lived outside the great sioux reservation
in 1874 the united states government dispatched
the seventh cavalry to the black hills inside
the dakota territory their mission was to scout
for a suitable location for a new fort but also to
search the area for natural resources specifically
they were to investigate a rumor that there might
be gold in the black hills this was a time when
america was firmly gripped with gold fever the
california gold rush had a massive effect on the
country's economy and its migration toward the
west so the possibility of a similar scenario
in dakota was just too good to ignore therefore
on july the 2nd 1874 a thousand soldiers and 110
wagons set off on the black hills expedition led
by lieutenant colonel george armstrong custer the
california gold rush also had a devastating effect
on the native american population and in august
1874 the worst thing possible for them happened
custer found gold in the black hills he described
as an extensive area rich in gold deposit and
in just a week the new york tribune proclaimed
the black hills to be new gold country nowhere in
custer's report or the newspapers was it mentioned
that the land was the gold was legally the lakotas
by autumn over 15 000 miners have already made
their way to the dakota territory at first
the army was there to arrest and evacuate the
prospectors who snuck into lakota land although
it was mainly saving them from being killed by the
native americans the government made an offer of
six million dollars to purchase the black hills an
offer which was firmly rejected by sitting bull at
that point president ulysses s grant pretty much
said screwed the treaty and pulled the army from
the region allowing people to travel unimpeded
to the black hills in december 1875 grant gave
a deadline of january 31 1876 by which point all
the sioux people had to relocate inside the great
sioux reservation those who failed to do so would
be considered and treated as hostiles even if
sitting bull would have been willing to move which
he wasn't it would have been almost impossible
to do it in such a short time and during the
middle of winter therefore he saw no other choice
the deadline passed and the great sioux war began
word of sitting bull's refusal to accept any kind
of deal with the american government reached other
tribes that were living outside the great zoo
reservation the first half of 1876 or many of
them make their way to sitting bull's camp which
soon turned into a village with around 10 000
people on the bank of the little bighorn river
these were mainly lakota and dakota sioux but
also some northern cheyenne and arapaho the
exact number of warriors remains disputed to
this day but it's generally estimated to
be around 2 000 and besides sitting bull
other prominent leaders included garl and the
famed warrior crazy horse the opening skirmish
of the conflict which was also known as the black
hills war occurred in may 1876 when six cavalry
troops led by colonel joseph j reynolds attacked a
native american village in montana's powder river
valley reynolds split his army into four groups
but due to a miscalculation from the colonel
only one reached the village in time although they
managed to destroy the village they also sustained
casualties and ultimately were forced to retreat
for his actions reynolds was later charged with
dereliction of duty and court-martialed another
notable fight was the battle of rosebud on june
17 named after montana's rosebud creek this was
a bigger affair that included around a thousand
soldiers on each side but like the first one
sitting bull was not involved rather this one
saw general george crook go against crazy horse
and his oglala lakota warriors crook also had
assistance from the crow and the shoshone who had
allied themselves with the u.s government in this
war but he still narrowly avoided a bloody
crushing defeat that would have seen most
of his troops wiped out technically he won the
battle because he had control of the battlefield
when it was said and done but this is usually
regarded as a strategic victory for the sioux
and the cheyenne they inflicted a lot of damage
and they retreated from the battlefield of their
own accord emboldened by their success against the
american army but most importantly they completely
immobilized crooks unit left with little supplies
and plenty of wounded crook soldiers would play
no part in the bigger battle that was about
to take place just a days later came the famed
battle of little bighorn known as the battle of
the greasy grass to the dakota originally the
army planned a three-pronged approach involving
three military columns coming from different
directions that would have culminated in one
big attack against sitting bull's village one
of those three columns was the one led by general
crook and that one had been eliminated by crazy
horse another one was led by colonel john gibbon
who had been delayed and was not in the area at
the time of the battle that left the third column
by general alfred terry on june 22nd terry sent a
scouting party ahead which consisted of the same
seventh cavalry regiment that first discovered
gold in the black hills once again commanded by
lieutenant colonel george armstrong custer on
the morning of june 25th custer found sitting
bull's camp and in a very fool-hearty move
decided not to wait for reinforcements he had
between 600 and 700 soldiers with him and he
thought that would be enough to defeat the lakota
even though he was uncertain of how many warriors
awaited him of course the lakota had their
own scout since sitting bull was aware of
the impending attack and was ready to strike back
we should mention that although sitting bull is
generally the native american closest associated
with this battle many sources claim that he didn't
actually fight by this point he would have been
in his mid to late 40s so his role was more of a
spiritual leader whereas the young braves
were led in battle by crazy horse and gall
it was around mid-afternoon that custard decided
to launch his attack and almost immediately it
became clear that he'd made a big mistake his 700
cavalry men were up against a force numbering in
the thousands and they were quickly overwhelmed
after just 20 minutes of fighting the lakota had
already gained the upper hand and had forced the
u.s soldiers to fall back kustra divided his army
into five groups and although they all sustained
heavy losses the brunt end was felt by the
detachment led by kuster himself they retreated to
higher ground where they were surrounded by their
enemies and killed the very last man this final
resistance became known as custer's last stand and
the place where it happened is now a memorial
called lost stand hill the battle had been a
disaster for the us army as it gave it its worst
defeat in all of its many wars against the sioux
however looking back at it it can also be regarded
as the beginning of the end for the dakota for
starters they had to go on the march immediately
since they knew that a stronger army would have
followed but this also forced the government to
increase its efforts against the zoo dramatically
besides bringing in thousands of extra soldiers it
also applied great pressure on the native tribes
within the reservation to meet the non-treaty
leaders and convince them to surrender even
cutting off their rations until they succeeded
chief red cloud was the one who led this
delegation and he convinced many of the people
led by crazy horse to surrender on may 5 1877.
once again sitting ball had no interest in a
treaty with the government so when the others
surrendered he took his group of a few hundred
hunk papa lakota across the northern border but
life in canada proved very difficult the winters
were cold and the buffalo were scarce more and
more people were leaving sitting bull's
tribe and returning to the reservation
ultimately after four years of harsh living
the lakota leader omitted defeat in 1881 he
returned to the united states and surrendered
to the american government at first sitting
bull was placed under arrest and sent to stay
in an army fort but in 1883 he was released
and allowed to live on the standing rock
reservation there he still resisted change
particularly in his refusal to learn how to
farm to the annoyance of agents in charge of
the reservation sitting bull discovered that he
didn't need to learn in order to survive following
the battle of little bighorn the lakota chief had
become quite notorious in the country and people
were eager to meet him he began charging for
photographs and autographs and was able to live
off his newfound fame in 1884 sitting ball met
annie oakley the performing sharpshooter and the
two struck up a friendship as the lakota leader
was greatly impressed with her shooting skills
he even gave her the nickname little shoreshot a
moniker she adopted and began using in a stage act
soon afterwards sitting bull met another notable
figure of that era buffalo bill cody the man
who brought the wild west experience to people
all over the country and even in europe with
his touring show he convinced sitting ball to join
him a move that made the former warrior even more
famous it was pretty easy living sitting bull
made 50 a week plus another 1 per autograph and
all he had to do was ride around in a circle and
talk even so he only lasted for 4 months before it
decided to return to the reservation even though
sitting bull no longer had any official authority
he was still revered by the lakota something the
reservation agents greatly resented in the late
1880s a paiute religious leader named oavoka began
travelling from tribe to tribe and prophesizing a
resurgence of the native people something which
became known as the ghost dance movement this
worried the government because they feared that it
might cause the native americans to rise up again
and begin a new war they were particularly
concerned about the ghost dance movement gaining
support from prominent leaders and at the time
there was no living leader greater than sitting
bull on december 15 1890 reservation agent james
mclaughlin sent indian police to arrest sitting
bull they burst into his cabin early in the
morning and took him outside despite being close
to 60 years old the former warrior was as stubborn
and defiant as ever and refused to cooperate in
a short while the police were surrounded
by angry lakota men with guns and rifles
one of them took the first shot and in retaliation
the indian police opened fire on sitting bull
shooting him in the head and the chest killing
him almost instantly another dozen men also
died in the gunfight that ensued as for the ghost
dance movement the government took care of it just
two weeks later when it orchestrated the
wounded knee massacre killing between 150
and 250 lakota people many of them women and
children to show that it was prepared to crush
even the slightest into rebellion caused
by anger over the murder of sitting bull
so i really hope you enjoyed this video thank
you again to conflict of nations for sponsoring
remember if you want to jump into their
grand strategy game use the link in the
description below to start playing and
that'll get you the bonus 13 000 gold in
a month for free premium it's a very cool
deal and as always thank you for watching